the choice facing parliament
the choice facing labor is now whether
to accept that deal
or to reject it the deal is a thin
agreement it does not provide adequate
protections
for british manufacturing our financial
services
creative industries or workplace rights
it is not the deal that the government
promised
far from it and there are serious
questions
about the government's preparedness for
the new arrangements
as ever leaving everything to the last
minute
has made it even more difficult for
businesses to be ready
a better deal could have been negotiated
but i accept that that option that
option has now gone
the chance for renegotiation is over
there are just two paths now left for
our country
to move forward with a deal or without
one
no deal is simply not an option
the social economic and political
consequences
would be devastating jobs would be put
at risk
businesses would collapse investment
would dry up
our national security would be
threatened
the disruption that we've seen at the
port of dover in recent days
would be the tip of the iceberg and the
cumulative effect
on top of the worst recession of any
major economy
would be unimaginable labor is against
no deal
firmly and absolutely
and the british people would never
forgive us if we enabled a no deal
outcome there are some
that argue that labor should be neutral
on this issue to abstain
i do not agree leadership
is about taking the tough decisions in
the national interest
it's about being a serious responsible
opposition
a government in waiting
this is the deal that labour will
inherit in 2024
it's something we will build on compared
to the
chaos of no deal the public would expect
a labor government
to make it work and the eu would expect
us to make it work
and to use it to protect our shared
interests
including of course the peace process
in northern ireland at a moment of such
national significance it is just not
credible
for labor to be on the sidelines
and that's why i can say today
that when this deal comes before
parliament
labor will accept it and vote for it